it's a pantsuit no it's a jumpsuit it's
hard to tell because it's voluminous but
pants today y'all its pants I am like
what could barely possibly do this award
season to top the villainous of Billy
and this is it ridiculous it's so
fabulous because I have embraced what
old Hollywood used to be I love dressing
up I've always loved dressing up and the
fact that I've created this space where
I get the freedom to actually do
whatever I want
it's like fabulous it's so much fun fun
honestly I love but first of all your
talent is like next-level but I love
knowing you're coming to a carpet every
time we get excited because we're like
what are you going to bring and it's so
fun that you just like live in it I love
it it's an escape for us it's fashion
fashion is art its activism you know I'm
first-generation post-civil rights
movement you know we were taught that
the first impression is what you look
like so you know I'm a dresser up I've
always been and now I get to extend
beyond just the heteronormative but and
the tats hello and the nails the
butterflies are you know a symbol of the
transgender community
how you come from the cocoon and you
took you come as one thing and then you
transform into something else and so I
wanted to honor my my peeps tonight who
was the penalty box
Hogan mcLaughlin let's talk about the
reason you're here the acting and pose I
know that they've just gone back to
start writing season 3 what are your
hopes for season 3 because your season 2
was so emotional I mean I cried I was
like is he gonna make it we don't mean
it was it was like the best script
saying how do you guys even top this
well I don't know that I leave that to
the writers you know it's a difficult
story and it has to be told
honestly and that's the part that I'm
the most proud of is that you know we
get to see people who choose life anyway
you know through the darkest of times
and circumstances so I'm not sure what's
in store you know they don't tell us
much so but we started March okay we're
at the Critics Choice Awards so I would
like you to be your critic tell me well
your we know your greats tell me you're
worse like what was your worst gig your
worst role like the time that you bombed
and you like you look at it you're like
Oh Billy you know I did a show on
Broadway called Five Guys their mom
and I was understudying three different
characters and I had to do this tap
dance and I'm a good tap dancer but
there were tricks at the end of it that
like extreme dancers do that I couldn't
really do so the first time I went on
I've ripped my hamstring good night not
my proudest time
all right we're playing eat eat up the
question that came before
eat eat up where all the stars asked
people questions as we go so the
question before years was from Taye
Diggs what do you wear when you sleep I
sleep in my all together y'all know what
that means
naked y'all too young to know that
phrase
am i all together I don't know where it
came from
such an old woman and what do you want
to ask the next person it might be
Florence for you we don't know Florence
what are you what are you wearing
what is this crystal what do you Twp
well no we're gonna end it on this what
he teed up do you want ask for I just
asked her who she was wearing Prada love
you so good to see you babe
[Music]